saw this headline why the Cowboys knew
tony romo deadline doesn't make sense
Todd Archer of the mothership covers the
Cowboys kind enough to join us Todd good
morning why is Tony Romo Cilic a boy if
anybody can crawl inside Jerry Jones's
mind and figure this out good luck to ya
it doesn't make sense because we know
he's not going to be a cowboy in 2017
and we've had this time here where a
trade could happen and nothing's gone
down and Jerry Jones always tells us a
player's value is at its lowest point
right near the draft so nothing's going
to happen then and now you're running
into a situation where no one really
knows what's going on here people
certainly can make the point that Oh
Jerry's upset with Tony or Tony's upset
with Jerry and really none of this is
true it's just it just as it's
mind-boggling at the moment I don't
understand why I'm who hasn't been made
yet there's the end game for both sides
should be fairly clear and it should be
an easy decision to make but if I I look
at the situation we thought he was going
to be released back on March ninth I
believe and here we are at the end of
March now it looks like he's going to be
going to training camp I like are they
hoping for an injury around the NFL that
they can say hey Romo's here if you want
to trade for him perhaps but this whole
weight full of Satan can't thing if
that's the game that they want to play
and I'm Tony Romo I'll show up at the
facility up in Frisco Texas the star the
shiny new places they got put 800 pounds
on the squat rack get down there and
blow my back out and say hey where's my
14 million dollars the Cowboys don't
want to take that risk either but I have
yeah the vote the offseason program is
voluntary if you know the OTAs a
minicamp the only thing it is the June
minicamp is the only deal that has to
that a player has to attend so if you're
Romo show up to these things and then
you'll see how fast the cowboys make a
move on them because they don't want to
risk him getting hurt go back to Steve
McNair with the Tennessee Titans I
believe in 2006 they borrowed them for
the facility when is
number was huge and a judge ruled
against the Titans in that case and
eventually ended up with the Raven so
you're you're looking at that scenario
playing itself out here at some point if
Tony Romo blows out his back lifting
wage you're going to be the guy who
called it Todd I'll give you credit all
right that'll be your exclusive sources
close to you and thank you know is I
don't think they do them allow him to
get the 800 pounds in Iraq I think Jerry
would run down to the weight room say hi
Tony we're good we're going to release
you today buddy but he said that you
know this is on a cop's on his priority
list to take care of Tony Romo I i'm
going to guess they've had conversations
where he's telling him hey all do right
by you is he worried that he would that
Houston is the only option and maybe he
doesn't he'd rather him go to Denver
than houston I can't imagine the Texans
being not far down the road from here
would be an option in and Jerry Luke
fearing the loss of cowboys fans that
were more Romo fans and cowboys and I
don't think that is a scenario I I think
it's you know I also when Jerry says
something to go back to something Jerry
told us years ago just because I said it
doesn't make it so and you know the jury
I was on the bus when Jerry came up with
the do-right rule which seems like a
good line right now considering he
hasn't done right by the quarterback but
there is a benefit to Romo that
something hasn't happened yet from the
cowboys vs pected and it's this he
doesn't he's still in the process of
making his mind up do I want to play and
you know this has bought him some more
time to make that decision and and it
has people like me and maybe you guys
they're saying what are the cowboys
doing making putting the Cowboys and the
bad guy hat here and where Tony can sit
back and say do I want to play measure
out all these factors i have a young
family another child on the way I've had
these injuries I'm good financially for
the rest of my life you know this has
bought him some time and now you know
we've all thought well it's houston in
denver against each other well maybe now
it's fox and CBS bidding against each
other here and pumping up the price to
get Romo to join them so he has suitors
and options to go to it just might be in
a broadcast booth as opposed to on the
field
I going to Todd Archer the mothership
covers the Cowboys but I'm also looking
at that as well that Tony Romo as a game
analyst I see I see him more as a studio
analyst I think you want to take
advantage of seeing him as opposed to
hearing him and I know Troy Aikman has
made that seamless transition but you're
around Tony Romo do you see him going
into this business and being a game
analyst I can see him doing that yes you
know when the cameras aren't on from you
know now is the quarterback and Troy was
the same way even though I wasn't
covering the Cowboys back then everybody
said Troy was boring and dull and never
said anything but if you get Tony away
from the cameras and off to the side he
can explain football to you in a way
where an idiot like me understands
what's going on so I think that's where
people you know when you're watching the
game that's what you want I think Tony
would be actually really good at being
able to break down the game in a simple
way to show you all the things a quarter
of Italian what a quarterback sees but
what a defensive back sees when he's
been hurt these last few years he wears
that earpiece for a lot of reasons and
some of it is to listen to the play call
that's going into quarterback but he
wants to hear what the defensive coaches
a calling and saying and picking up that
part of the game too so he has a wide
knowledge of the game not just from the
quarterback size but from a lot of
people's eyes I think he'd be really
good at it his room a little better
quarterback than dak Prescott I yes and
you know that that might be one of the
reasons why Jerry Jones is not making
this move that he he wanted he wanted
this scenario where he'd have his
quarterback of the future paired with
romo and salary cap wife's he can do
this he can keep roma right now and the
Cowboys are under the cap there's no
move that they have to make but clearly
he never thought that deck would come in
and go 13 and 3b the offensive rookie of
the year but Tony at the level of
quarterback play Tony is better than dak
simply because of experience and
knowledge and knowing the game more
health Oh clearly is the biggest
obstacle in this situation because he's
only played in parts of five games of
last year's if Tony Romo is healthy
there's no question that he's better
than
Prescott right now and would be the
better quarterback for the Cowboys the
gift that keeps on giving the Dallas
Cowboys Todd thanks for joining us you
got to thanks I appreciate that scott
archer covers the Cowboys for ESPN the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience